how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about Marvel and of course everything
relating to the MCU today we're going to
be talking about Robert Downey jr. and
all of the buzz around him returning to
the MCU to reprise his role as Tony
Stark slash iron man and then we'll talk
about the x-men in the MCU as well and
how Iron Man and the x-men could
actually cameo in the same movie now if
you're unaware of the Robert Downey jr.
returning to marvel situation there have
been many various reports by many
different media outlets stating that
Robert Downey jr. has been talking with
Marvel Studios about his return and
reportedly his return comes down to two
different conditions one is money of
course always about the money
Robert Downey jr. essentially hung up
the role of Tony Stark / Iron Man in
Avengers in game when Tony Stark died he
was done with the role so you're gonna
have to offer him a pretty good amount
of money to return and the second
condition is that he wants to work with
Tom Holland the two of them obviously
got close to one another they worked
together on spider-man homecoming and of
course in Captain America Civil War
infinity war and Avengers end game not
to mention they both work together in
Doolittle so this was the report Robert
Downey jr. was considering returning to
Marvel Studios to play the role of Iron
Man once again important to note not
reviving the character Iron Man is dead
that is not going to be reversed but as
rumor has it due to the failure of
Doolittle he has lowered his amount to
come back to Marvel Studios and
apparently him and Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios have reached
an agreement and Robert Downey jr. will
be coming back now this isn't confirmed
yet although many people are reporting
this however there are three very likely
movies in which Robert Downey jr. could
return in that fit perfectly and they're
all in phase four so let's talk about
this and the x-men if you're new be sure
to subscribe when notifications turned
on so you can stay up to date on all
things relating to the MCU and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or ps4 now there has
been some rumors going around that
Robert Downey jr. could be returning as
Iron Man in an Iron Heart series however
we have heard absolutely nothing about
an Iron Heart series being anywhere near
pre development at Marvel Studios we
haven't even heard anything as much as
it being talked about
there are many Disney Plus series or
development
and we pretty much know what they all
are not to mention Robert Downey jr.
probably wouldn't want to return for a
series it will most likely be a cameo
for a short scene in one movie and like
I said there are three very likely
options in which these movies could be
and the first movie is Black Widow now
there have been reports and leaks
stating that Robert Downey jr. does make
an appearance as Iron Man in the Black
Widow film it's unconfirmed but this
does fit perfectly black widow takes
place right after the events of Civil
War and even though Natasha is kind of
on Tony's side in the beginning she
essentially betrays him and therefore
becomes a fugitive and then goes on the
run but Tony has a very long
relationship with Natasha they've been
through a lot together and just like in
Captain America Civil War Tony Stark
offered to go get the Avengers first
before Ross went looking for them and
this will most likely happen again after
the events of Civil War Tony Stark will
say I will go get Natasha I'll talk to
her I'll bring her in for you now this
would mean that a deal for Robert Downey
jr. to return as Iron Man to the MCU was
made quite some time ago it's only just
now coming out and we do have some
leaked photos that are supposedly Tony
Stark in the Black Widow film getting
off of his private jet now these are
unverified meaning that we don't know if
it truly is for the black widow film but
it sure does seem like it and some leaks
have said that Robert Downey jr. is in
the movie so we could be seeing Iron Man
in Black Widow and this works because it
takes place before Avengers in game so
obviously he's not dead yet another
perfect film for him to pop up in is
spider-man 3 one of his conditions is
again reportedly working with Tom
Holland well if that truly is one of the
conditions on his return to the MCU then
he's definitely going to have to be in
spider-man 3 and if we think about how
he could return in spider-man 3
it fits perfectly as well perhaps
spider-man far from home wasn't as
revealing as we thought it was after all
pretty much the whole thing took place
in Europe Tony Stark probably left Peter
Parker a lot of stuff and he most likely
left him access to whatever labs that he
had before the snap and whatever labs he
built during the five-year gap not to
mention happy is looking after him and
we know that he's going to be a major
part of Stark Industries as well as
Pepper
Peter probably has access to basically
anything that Tony Stark
Peter was like a son to him and not to
mention he's a genius so what could
happen is that we could see Tony Stark
as some sort of AI artificial
intelligence or we could see him as a
hologram a hologram would make sense it
would kind of be like the hologram that
he left to Morgan and pepper at the end
of Avengers endgame except this one
would be specifically for Peter and in
fact it would make perfect sense that
while he was trying to discover
time-travel and once he did discover
time-travel he realized that he was
going to have to go back in time and
realize that he might not make it back
that's why he recorded the message for
pepper and Morgan and since Peter was
like a son to him and he missed him very
dearly it's more than likely that he
left a message for Peter as well and the
president's for Peter to receive that
message in spider-man 3 is set Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
has already stated that spider-man 3 is
going to be unlike the first two
spider-man films and he stated that
Peter is going to really come into his
character and he's going to be on his
own and spider-man homecoming he had
Tony Stark and spider-man far from home
he had happy well apparently in
spider-man 3 since he is going to be on
the run as a fugitive he's not going to
have anybody to help him but we know at
some point there is going to be a
breaking point Peter Parker is going to
be in a lot of trouble and he's not
going to know what to do and this is
where the message from Tony Stark would
fit perfectly think of a message left to
Peter from Tony Stark of him telling him
that he's really proud of them that he
knows that he can accomplish anything
that he puts his mind to and that he
knows he's going to go on to do great
things and lead the Avengers that's
definitely the motivation that Peter
Parker would need to kick himself in
gear and take on whoever the villain is
going to be in spider-man 3 and also
Tony did leave Peter glasses now the AI
Edythe stands for even dead I'm the hero
and the fact that he titled at édith
means that he was preparing in advance
for his death and he planned to leave
Peter those glasses
so a message from Tony to Peter makes
total sense and he could even show up as
AI himself and the last movie would not
only bring Iron Man back to the MCU but
would have him show up in a movie where
the x-men could appear as well and that
is Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness now this won't exactly be the
same version of Tony Stark that we know
from the main Marvel Cinematic Universe
timeline but as we know
multiple new timelines have been created
from the events of Avengers endgame and
based off of everything that we know
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to deal with those
alternate realities that were created
this is the perfect opportunity for a
final cameo from Robert Downey jr. as
Tony Stark
they simply bring him in the movie as an
alternate version of himself that way
his death isn't erased but we still get
our Iron Man cameo and not to mention it
has been reported that the Illuminati
could show up in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness now the Illuminati
consists of six different heroes Doctor
Strange
Black Bolt Charles Xavier Reed Richards
Namor the Submariner
and Iron Man now Iron Man is the one who
originally brought these characters
together to form the Illuminati and even
though Iron Man is dead in our current
timeline that doesn't mean that Doctor
Strange couldn't check with other
Illuminati's that exists in alternate
realities it's there where we could see
Tony Stark make his return and as I
mentioned another big part of the
Illuminati is Charles Xavier he
represents the x-men in the Illuminati
and we actually kind of have evidence to
support the fact that Charles Xavier is
coming to the MCU very soon and the most
likely film that he'll appear in first
is Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness recently Patrick Stewart who
plays the original Professor Xavier from
the original Fox x-men films revealed
that he recently met with Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige to talk about
Charles Xavier and according to Patrick
Stewart Marvel does have plans for
Professor X soon in a recent interview
he said I met with Kevin Feige
a couple of months ago and we had long
long conversations and there have been
moves and suggestions which include
Charles Xavier so we know that there are
plans or moves as Patrick Stewart says
for Charles Xavier to be in the MCU
relatively soon and we know that Patrick
Stewart isn't going to return to play
Professor X for another 10 years in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so that means
they were planning or at least thinking
of planning to bring him back for a
cameo and where would a cameo make sense
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe well
the perfect way for this to
in would be to have Patrick Stewart play
professor X but from a different
universe an alternate reality created
from a vendor's in game and in this
universe the illuminati could exist in
which Professor X Patrick Stewart's
professor X could be a part of that
Illuminati and also iron man as well
Robert Downey jr. Zion man so not only
could dr. strange in the multiverse of
madness bring back Robert Downey jr.
iron man but it could be the film to
introduce the x-men if dr. strange forms
the Illuminati Professor X is most
likely going to be a part of that just
like in the comics and it's very clear
based off of Kevin Feige mentioning the
word mutants at San Diego comic-con of
2019 and the fact that Patrick Stewart
revealed his meeting with Kevin Feige
talking about Professor X and the MCU
it's very clear that the x-men are on
their way soon so what do you think
about Robert Downey jr. possibly
returning to the MCU which film would
you like him to be in let me know your
thoughts and the comments down below
don't forget to like the video if you
enjoyed it and subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU you can follow me on Twitter for
live updates on things that are
happening in the MCU and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof